you posted another picture of you as a  kid what's happening here of course we  all know that you're you're sitting on a  on a potty I think it's called a  portable Tootsie yes okay yeah and but  you seem very happy what's happening  there oh this is when my parents began  to realize perhaps I will be an  entertainment person so I must be ready  at all times for the paparazzi so in any  moment it can be while I'm I don't know  making the pseudo-code puzzle or sewing  some denim they will just scream  paparazzi and then I have to be very  excited and happy right so you were  using the bathroom and you're one of  your parents shouted paparazzi and took  a photo always both all the ways both  one with camera one with screaming mama  screams steady clicks okay and that's  how they got a picture of you and you  see I look prepared yeah you look like  you're very happy to see the paparazzi  paparazzi